miss cook from your experience of
previous disasters and and disaster
relief efforts you think there are some
important points to bear in mind well
it's an extremely challenging situation
out there because of the uh that the
country itself struggling the government
itself is struggling to support the any
response at all uh all the all the
factors are against the mood the
infrastructure is very challenged the
geography is very challenging uh the
country is very poor anyway has a very
poor response capability itself so it's
relying heavily on international aid to
come in and do the whole the whole
support process really and we'll put
these points in a moment to mr dwyer but
you feel that the united nations
organization of response
sometimes
doesn't have the power really to get it
right well they're they're quite reliant
on the the the sovereignty of the
country themselves to to invite teams in
and coordinate the responsible country
the u.n in these sorts of situations and
it was very similar in haiti where the
un have to try and take on really the
whole responsibility of what a national
government would try and do in most
cases so they have a really overwhelming
challenge in front of them to do that
and in this situation it's uh it can be
very challenging from the point of view
that aid is coming from all around the
world in all sorts of shapes and guises
and is really difficult to coordinate so
it's a really upright struggle for him
in this situation i mean mr dwyer is is
he the problem i mean of course you have
to respect the sovereignty of the
countries uh which you're trying to help
but does that
sometimes mean it's less effective than
it might be
well in nepal the the leadership of the
country the top leadership of the
country has been very quick to ask for
the assistance of the international
community and has absolutely welcomed
the coordination of the united nations
in that so that in itself is not a
problem in nepal what is the problem in
nepal is just the massive scale of the
earthquake and the massive scale of the
of the of the losses and the damage and
exactly as mr cook uh said the the
national authorities don't themselves
have uh all of the set up able to handle
this but but almost no country could if
in these geographical uh situations but
also uh the weather is is is very very
difficult the existing infrastructure
even before it was damaged was not up to
to to a quick response so for example
the challenge that we have at the
airport to make sure that it does not
get clogged up and that aids supplies
rescue teams can get in people can get
out as they need to including indeed
commercial goods can come in and out so
there are massive challenges but this
essentially stems from the the
incredible suddenness that an earthquake
brings in the massive scale of this
earthquake the nepali authorities are
challenged uh but they're very committed
uh the nepali police and military are
very engaged the the neighbor the
neighboring countries are very engaged
and we do see aid coming in from all
over the world coordinating that is
indeed a challenge but we're working 24
7 on this we're in day four since the
quake itself hit
what about dealing with people because
obviously they have very very urgent
needs they're desperate
that too presumably is a priority which
might not be if you're in a clinical
environment uh necessarily uh the top
one well the obviously the first
response that you've seen already is the
search and rescue teams that go in in
the very early stages they tend to move
fastest and get on the ground very very
quickly to try and do the rescue and
that in itself is a challenge and very
quickly as was mentioned there the
coordination needs to move on to look
after the people's longer term needs the
food the water the shelter so it changes
very rapidly in those early stages and
that whole coordination and linking up
those different aspects those different
parts of the process goes on and on we
see the headlines in the news with the
with the rescue side of it you don't see
what goes on for weeks and months
afterwards a more complex and difficult
challenge mr dwyer how does it work do
you have as it were in reserve
the resources that the united nations
needs to respond to a situation like
this or is it a question of having to go
around the member nations and get them
to contribute
our office the the coordination the
office for the coordination of
humanitarian affairs has standby
arrangements with member countries with
all around the world
so that when a disaster strikes like
this
we
they already have their personnel and
their equipment on standby and move
immediately so it's not a question of
the united nations itself having uh
stockpiles
or staff on hand with all of the
technical expertise but the search and
rescue teams are coming from a large
number of member states but they were
already lined up and ready to come in at
a a moment's notice when you have a
disaster like this so that system is has
worked well here in nepal there's been a
challenge getting people in in that
airport as i had said but we have over
500 international search and rescue
people on the ground right now with
teams of dogs um trying to get through
rubble and fine people but the the
greatest challenge to that effort now
and and i you saw it in the lead up to
to this part of the program is getting
outside of kathmandu to these incredibly
remote communities and it is true that
in any situation like this
it is the communities themselves who are
the first responders and who
have to operate alone until assistance
can get out to them that's proving still
to be a massive challenge in many of
these very remote areas in nepal
thank you both very much indeed thank
you